PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
a developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
And in this video,
I'll show you how
to create an e-commerce
website with Google Cloud.
There are multiple ways to
create a retail website.
In this video, I'll walk you
through one such approach
called headless commerce.
Headless commerce is
where you decouple
the frontend, your mobile app,
your CMS, from your backend
or your commerce layer.
This approach
provides flexibility
to your marketing
teams to quickly alter
frontend elements to run
campaigns and promotions
and create the most
advanced customer experience
for any frontend device.
By the end of this
video, you will
understand the basics of how
to build a headless commerce
application.
You will see a frontend
experience deployed
on Cloud Run in Google
Cloud, and integrate it
with commerce backend from
Google Cloud Marketplace
offering partner,
Commerce Tools.
All right.
Let's get started.
First things first.
If you logged into the
console for the first time,
create a project.
A project is required
to use Google Cloud
and forms the basis of
creating, enabling, and using
all the Google Cloud services.
I'm going to be using this
one for our demo today.
On the left navigation,
select Billing
and link your billing account.
Go to billing any
time for an accurate,
up to date picture of
your Cloud spending.
You can view all products
and learn more about them,
read documentation,
work on a quick start,
and even navigate to
individual products.
If you prefer to use the
command line interface,
from the top right corner,
you can activate Cloud Shell,
which is an online
terminal preloaded
with utilities such as
the GCloud, Command Line
Tool, QCTL, and more.
Now that you know how to
navigate through the console,
let's look into the
headless commerce project.
Here you have the
Cloud Run instance
for our e-commerce frontend.
It is built on
[INAUDIBLE] storefront
and deployed in a
serverless container.
If you are wondering why we
are using Cloud Run here,
it's because it allows you to
deploy serverless containers.
You don't need to
worry about scaling
up or down as traffic
patterns change.
Once the service
is deployed, you
can see it in the Cloud
Run Service Details page.
And here is what the
service looks like.
In order for this to work, we
need to plug into a backend.
So let's talk about
the backend now.
We could just create
a backend ourselves.
But that would
require us to create
all the microservices for
products, orders, cards, et
cetera.
And we have an
example for that here.
Creating your own backend
can be a lot of work
and can be time consuming, time
which your development team can
spend elsewhere, which
is why, in this solution,
we are using a headless
approach, a faster way
to connect with
pre-built backend APIs.
The benefit of this
approach is that you
can update the frontend without
having to touch the backend.
This separation
also makes it easier
to update the frontend
while maintaining compliance
with security and other
standards for the backend.
It also helps with maintaining
consistent performance
for the end-to-end
client experience
as you apply updates
to your frontend.
All right.
So how do we actually do this?
We have Google
Cloud Marketplace,
which offers quick deploy
software solutions.
The partners such as
Commerce Tools on Marketplace
allows you to create
this integration
right inside the console.
After setting up a trial
account on Commerce Tools
and logging in, I
created an API client
to connect the frontend with the
Commerce Tools back end, which
offers products, categories,
customers, orders,
and other services.
After both the frontend
and backend are set up,
we can deploy the website
and see that it works.
And as we saw at the
beginning of this tutorial,
the storefront on
Cloud Run can be
accessed at the deployed URL.
You can also see the logs
and metrics in the Cloud Run
deployed service with
request count, latency,
billable instance time, and
other utilization metrics.
You just learned how to build
a headless commerce application
with frontend
experience deployed
on Cloud Run and backend APIs on
Commerce Tools in Google Cloud
Marketplace.
Thanks for watching.
I encourage you to sign
up for a free trial
and follow this
tutorial yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]